[Musik]
option
ich musste da konnte wald
wie man der pc kam mit dem oktopus
eine liebevolle begegnung auf augenhöhe
zwischen zwei wesen wie sie
unterschiedlicher nicht sein könnten
diese vision lockt natalie küttel in die
arme eines octopus
ich habe sie bei diesem vorhaben acht
monate begleitet
[Musik]
die institution schüler bei gmail im
kanton waadt ein hof mit einer
besonderen mission
im zentrum steht das friedliche
zusammenleben von tier und mensch rund
zehn artisten und 80 tiere leben hier
und erforschen die präsenz von tieren im
theater das shampoo lab ist natalies
arbeitgeber und zweites zuhause
hier gibt sie theater und zirkus kurse
und steht als schauspielerin regelmäßig
auf der bühne besucht wie der bcg
täglich und das mit weihbischof dressage
machen
seit 14 jahren rückt natalie ihre starke
bindung mit tieren ins scheinwerferlicht
zb im stück yoga blog oder im stück
brennende liebe
jetzt will die westschweizerin
ausgerechnet mit einem oktopus auf die
bühne
das schwierigste in einem aquarium für
kraken muss alles stimmen temperatur
anteile an salz nitrit nitrate phosphor
und bakterien im wasser vor sechs jahren
löste ein dokumentarfilm über oktopusse
natalies obsession aus daraufhin reiste
sie nach napoli ins meeresbiologische
institute und lernte die meerestiere
erstmals mehr kennen
für sie nicht namenlose
forschungsobjekte sondern
persönlichkeiten
panikmache ist es ist einfach ein name
keinen oktopus es ist ein seminar berna
der sybil nachher eine klette biologie
faire woche mit milchfett zeigt wie man
wasser kontrollieren
sie präparieren erklärt und nachricht
ferien kommen
wie beliebt mitte oktober die alex ii bv
acht stunden später klingelt wasser
dauert die analyse im labor schafft dem
ikonischen
zurück in der schweiz hat sie sich mit
ihrem team fünf jahre auf das projekt
vorbereitet
jetzt sind sie bereit zwei oktopusse in
die schweiz zu holen
[Musik]
ein milliliter
fünf monate vor der theaterpremiere
anfang september 2020 begleite ich
natalie nach südfrankreich auf der reise
erzählt natalie von ihrer faszination
für die oktopusse
weil ich ganz
[Musik]
die eu hat die selbe hut wachsen angst
machen
die natur intelligenz als schlüssel zum
überleben
oktopusse können planvoll handeln und
schnell lernen das ist für weichtiere
einzigartig set an der französischen
mittelmeerküste natalie und ihr team
treffen den berufsfischer eric belohne
einer der wenigen der nicht mit der
harpune fest und so die oktopusse nicht
verletzt ich töte sie nicht sie leben
recht lange außerhalb vom wasser ich
transportiere sie lebendig zum
fischmarkt
ali kur soll
das ist das boot auf dem ich arbeite und
hier sind die oktopusse den weißen da
den haben sie gefressen
er ist ganz ruhig ich sehe die tentakel
ihr habt also euren kollegen gefressen
in den fässern werden die kranken
transportiert den salzgehalt vom er
vergleicht die schauspielerin mit den
werten von ihrem aquarium 38 das ist
verrückt das ist normalerweise bei 35
[Musik]
dadurch komme es auch zu wenig
sorgfältig nicht dass der tinte sprit er
wollte nicht bei mir bleiben
der hat seinen kollegen gefressen
achtung
macht euch keine sorgen
für diese zwei tiere hält das schicksal
eine spezielle wende bereit anstelle vom
fischmarkt wo sie für 20 euro verkauft
werden wartet eine theaterkarriere ich
glaube wir haben alles
wir sind verrückt
[Musik]
ich schließe wegen der klimaanlage
klimaanlage auf die höchste stufe hast
du einen pullover auch gleich
ich hoffe die belebende hatten heißt ein
hafen der transport in die schweiz ist
der erste härtetest für natalie und ihr
team immer wieder sehen sie nach den
klaren
er ist ganz weiß geht es ihm gut oder
nicht weiß nicht ich will nicht rein
fassen hat der tinte gespritzt
nein nein das ist es nicht ich weiß
nicht aber angst hat vor mir wieso weiß
ist
wenn du ihnen angst macht dann werden
sie weiß
jetzt ist es wieder besser er nimmt
jeder farbe an
ich glaube ich habe ihm angst gemacht
bis die weichtiere in den aquarien sind
bleibt die lage angespannt
noch vor ankunft in gmail wurden die
tiere gekauft sie heißen akt und z wie
ihre heimatorte die spritzen uns gleich
an sagt das nicht wenn alles klappt
bringt natalie die kraken nach einer
europa tournee zurück ins meer
wie viel zeit dafür bleibt ist jedoch
ungewiss kraken werden höchstens zwei
bis drei jahre alt okay machen wir kurz
die analysen nur die sonden ph-wert
temperatur
jetzt müssen sie das wasser vom
transport dem wasser der aquarien
angleichen
fünf stunden lang ich habe das gefühl
inmitten einer herzoperation zu stehen
das wasser ist bei 814 817 weiter warten
dann endlich der große moment
[Musik]
1600 saugnäpfe auf entdeckungstour
das ist das schönste ist
[Musik]
größenordnung
zum heurigen ja wir müssen besser zu tun
was ich liebe ja heute man kann man da
so wenig sorgen
deshalb sei ein jahr des säens der pkk
kontrolliert aus gut geschlafen
beides colo
ganz langsam
bis zum nacken oder es nicht und es ist
ganz ruhig sein
oktopusse sind in der regel schüchtern
und leben einsam
trotzdem sind sie neugierig bis zu den
ersten bühnenproben bleibt ein monat
zeit für natalie akt und sich näher zu
kommen
[Musik]
das elternhaus in rom
ich begleite die 46 jährige zu ihrer
mutter um herauszufinden wie das mit den
tieren angefangen hat natalies eltern
haben beruflich tiere präpariert tot
oder lebendig tiere waren in ihrer
kindheit allgegenwärtig
[Musik]
wenn sie als am morgen
schale
[Musik]
seit einem monat leben die zwei kraken
im spiel ab verblüfft beobachte ich die
beziehungs fortschritte zwischen akzent
und natalie täglich spielen sie mehrere
stunden praxis mit tennis besser die
heute gar nicht mehr
und da helfe ich gern mit der blieb so
auf der hand wo ich auch so blieb sechs
spieler so weites lapentti wohl leider
keinem spieler locker was passiert so
lustig wie gehabt mit ihm mit der bbc
nehmen sie mit und erhält gibt mir schon
wieder in die höhe
es ist ihre fans können mit einem
kollegen briefe alles
300 liter umfasst die spielwiese der
beiden karten die finanzierung der
professionellen anlage wurde dank der
zusammenarbeit mit dem theater die wie
die möglich im januar findet die
ausverkaufte premiere statt noch vier
monate zeit für die erste bühnenprobe
stefan kaegi führt regie mit einem
lichtkonzept videoprojektionen
tonaufnahmen und live musik inszeniert
das team die begegnung zwischen natalie
und dem oktopus
was während einer vorstellung passiert
ist ungewiss ob ihr mal ein bisschen mit
ihm zu spielen ein bisschen nach rechts
da hast du ein bisschen licht
schau mal ob er deine hand verfolgt
[Musik]
wendisch an machte bis geht es gut
april
manches bewegt ganz fest ein monat bis
zur premiere
wie jeden tag fährt natalie zu ihren
achtarmigen bühnen partnern
sie lebt in einer beziehung kinder hat
sie keine
zumindest keine richtigen
sie ist nicht
der beste unterhalter
es gebe den ärzten batterie
die wachsen
[Musik]
die schauspielerin tut alles damit es
den tieren so gut wie möglich geht jeden
tag stellt sie die zwei
intelligenzbestien vor ein neues retten
[Musik]
für nathalie unzählige arbeitsstunden
für die oktopusse sieben monate
freiheitsentzug
das projekt hat seinen preis der soll
sich auszahlen
[Musik]
ja
hätte ich meine shows wie wichtig das
projekt mit oktopus ja das soll ja
eigentlich schon
und was machen das im natur ein oktopus
jedes mal wenn ein kabarett xii
das kann man nicht finden oder sich
besser
freiheit ohne jeden tag viele chopins
gewinne ins hotel minispiele
mit sie ist das körperfett gar monate
bis sie beruhigen
es sind zwei jahren eine beziehung habe
außer von masse wenn du bist im wasser
pokalspiel mit dem spiel kommen
und das für mich ja
die machen das war ihm egal was
[Musik]
was sie schon länger es ist mein major
im wasser bin immer occean oder es ist
wie mich nur für in der regel worte um
ein doktor bizarre um dann nimmt was mit
nummer nach 150
definiert sich dass sich nummer
[Musik]
damit könnte sie damit
januar 2021 im theater die wie die bei
lausanne trotz lockdown findet heute die
primäre stadt ist gut
für die vorstellungen wechseln sich die
oktopusse ab heute kontakt zum zug
[Musik]
er gibt mir einen kuss
das wasser ist kalt
[Musik]
die konzentration auf die bühne
wegen den corona maßnahmen ist die
aufführung ausschließlich für
veranstalter nur gerade 20 personen
werden zeugen der weltpremiere ein
octopus im theater
mainz afp im begriff sind die stufen
machen
das ist ganz ruhig ganz richtig
ich spiele mit dem
da einfach akzeptiert glaube dass wir
noch nie passiert so was passiert für
sich
es ist das war interessant ist ein krieg
[Musik]
not
nach 75 minuten erwarte ich aus einer
fantasiewelt zwölf vorstellungen zeigt
dass der tvd dann beendet corona die
europa tournee und das projekt vorzeitig
zwei wochen später treffe ich natalie
aufgelöst bei ihr zu hause
[Musik]
der frage ob sie schon kompliziert mit
dem querschnitt einschnitte über die
nacht fahren
für akt geht die warterei zu lange er
stirbt in der schweiz
[Musik]
es ist gut für die oktoberfest anhimmelt
es ist nicht es ist die ganze zeit was
technisch und wenn ja der ganze projekt
himmel
die idee von derstandard.at es wichtig
[Musik]
meine hand mit de airbus diskutieren was
war ich ob es mit
einen monat nach der theaterpremiere
treffe ich natalie zum letzten mal
sie hatte sich ein ambitioniertes ziel
gesteckt der welt zu zeigen dass mensch
und octopus eine beziehung aufbauen
können
auf dem weg hat sie viele grenzen
überwunden
dann kam corona
meine spieler immer ohne theater um mehr
über mich seit der causa ist das möglich
aber es ist so glücklich für die ganze
experience was mir da ich glaube mir ja
klasse weg gemacht
für das bin ich glücklich
die lüthi 2 möglich macht
sie fasziniert
das danke
[Musik]
aber für mich der personalität ihn
erhobene tirol
[Musik]
sobald wie möglich will natalie set in
einem naturschutzgebiet in südfrankreich
freilassen
[Musik]